this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday march the [__]
second a beautiful day to be alive the
joint is brought to you by freeze pipe
the best you get a nice cold hit every
time here's how it works the pipe comes
with a detachable chamber that you
freeze beforehand when you're ready to
[__] go the smoke passes through the
frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale you
understand me your smoke will be so cold
you think you're [__] frosty the
snowman listen guys you know me when it
comes to smoking reefer i'm a [__]
professional i don't know about wines or
beers and all that [__] i know about
reefer and bongs and this bong is
[__] tremendous whether it's the bong
the bubbler or the pipe i smoke with a
[__] pipe and it's tremendous it's
non-toxic it freezes faster than water
and it stays frozen longer freeze type
cools down the smoke by hundreds of
degrees like you lived in [__]
colorado with uncle joey in the 80s
scoop a little snow and put in the bung
and [__] get ready to see the devil
so do me a favor go to freezepipe.com
and press and code joey to save 10
percent off your first order this is a
tremendous gift to get yourself get get
a bong a pipe or a bubbler that's the
freezepipe.com
and press code joey j o e y
to save ten percent you're gonna love it
if you can smoke from it freeze pipe
makes it the joint is also brought to
you by manscaped listen if you're like
me you know
your balls smell [__] gross all right
but uncle joey and manscape are sending
you the [__] showers while you're in
there manscape is turning men's shower
dreams into a favorite routine with an
all-new premium [__] collection save
big by going to manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with code
diaz diaz
listen to me my shower is tremendous i
get up in the mornings
i [__] brush my teeth i gargle i wash
i [__] think do my face with that
whatever then i hit the [__]
lawnmower 4.0 then i lather on the
cologne infused premium body wash with
aloe vera to keep your skin feeling
clean
and it moisturizes me all day i'm like
ashy joey next apply the two-in-one
shampoo and conditioner that cleanses
and nourishes in one step
i can use it anywhere you got hair your
balls your [__] now
to keep the [__] bo at bay all day we
got aluminum free deodorant and it dries
clear you got tattoos dry skin hit your
skin with the hydrating body
moisturizing spray and before you step
out the door
manscape lip balm that free gift to you
you understand me you're gonna [__]
love the lip balm
in fact give it to your girlfriend so
when she you [__] manscaped she could
suck the manscape right off your helmet
i'm gonna get you 20 percent off plus
free shipping with code diaz at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at
manscape.com use code diaz it's time to
take a shower [__] clean your
balls with [__] manscape shower
routine the joint is also brought to you
oh [__]
[__] draftkings it's covington and
maz vidal
they step into the octagon this sadly
ufc 272 you got edwin barboza on that
[__] you got rafael dos anos his
competitor just fell out but he's got a
new [__] anyway
the official sports premium partner unif
of the usc has a knockout offer better
dollar on the main event most vidal
versus covington and get a hundred
dollars in free bets you understand me
ready for [__] march madness
could be the first round knockout
majority draw a double knockout
resulting in no contest no matter the
outcome you get [__] paid laid and
parlayed [__] if sportsbook isn't
your thing listen draftkings
has the fantasy free pools tremendous
everyone can enter a free pool with ten
thousand dollars in prizes answer of a
handful of questions how long will the
fight last who will walk out a winner
who's blowing smoke whatever download
the draftkings sportsbook app today
right now use promo code joey and throw
down one dollar on ufc 272 main event
and get 100 and free bets no matter the
outcome that's code joey this saturday
march the [__] fifth at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting part in the ufc
21 over restrictions apply
all right without further ado let's get
this [__] party started jack
[Music]
hey how you doing
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the [__] joint it's
wednesday
march the [__] second a
beautiful [__] day to be alive i'm
feeling good
nothing's going on we did a [__] zoom
today
listen you know me guys i don't [__]
like zooms too much that's why i come on
in and bore you to death for [__] uh
every week but this week we had to go
for a zoom next week i'm getting a
couple zooms because listen i can't do
all the [__] talking you know i'm
saying i need somebody to [__] break
me down and uh make me laugh and
entertain me also so
we had a good [__] zoom today so
without further ado i'm just gonna bring
it up because listen i've been over here
talking to you [__]
breaking your [__] ears somebody sent
me a picture they hear bleeding and [__]
like that
you know i've been given tremendous ear
beatings i don't want to give a [__]
hear beating all right you don't have to
tell me joey give it a [__] breather
so without further ado i'm going to give
you uh jessie may paluso we've been
talking
throughout the whole pandemic i kept in
touch with her because she's one of my
dear friends in la and uh
you know she lost her mom during the
pandemic so i kept uh in touch with her
pretty much and she was ready to come on
the joint so i told her i said come on
whenever you want to she said let's do a
zoom next week so here we [__] are so
without further ado a little jessame
peluso
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
hi
cutie up beautiful
oh you look so cute look at you you look
so [__] beautiful
what's going on beautiful long time
long [__] time i like that wanted
richard pryor up behind you
yep i got that beautiful
got a little johnny cash up here johnny
cash
your girl's smoking a joint i swear
what's been going on beautiful
xenophobe it's from the movie alien it's
the it's the baby alien that goes on
your face and then it puts its semen and
down your throat and then it makes
another alien in your belly
tremendous
[__] tremendous you look beautiful
jess i'm a thank you you know i was
working out before and this is my sports
bra and i was like you know this is kind
of cute and for your male viewers they
can see a little quarantined boobies a
little cleavage
yeah a little quarantine cleavage
actually we're out of quarantine now i
guess right we're out of everything it's
over we're at war
[__] [__]
[__]
that's it
it's over that's it i knew it i [__]
knew it
really you know yeah that how long could
they milk it for people weren't [__]
dancing to that tune no more
we weren't dancing to that tune you know
so
covered was either they were gonna
[__] tighten [__] and then a riot was
gonna ensue eventually look what
happened in canada with the [__]
truckers
that i know i thank them because i think
that they're the ones that
really woke up the [__] world because
they were gonna do it in la for the
super bowl with the trucks [__]
block and everything you [__]
want to impose [__] on us we'll impose
[__] on you so
you know brave of them to do that in
canada they were you know
look at what's going on all of a sudden
all the mass just disappeared
that's it
sadly i got invited to a light mask and
[__] party like where you light them
on fire and [__]
but my mask i can't even let him i put a
mask on i could smell weed and [__]
thc juice in my mask the [__]
breathing is yellow i'm not lighting
those on fire i'm saving those
and if i ever run out of weed i just cut
them up and smoke those [__] masks
it is i was at a spot i was in palm
springs doing some shrooms over the
weekend and
on the tail end of my high trip i saw
ice cream spot so i went to go get some
ice cream and this is sunday it's the
day before
the masks are going to be lifted the
mandate's going to be lifted and i go
inside just mask free i'm like oh it's
sunday it's an ice cream shop they'll be
cool they're not gonna [__] worry
about it
and it's these two young kids behind the
counter and i was like i'll have you
know this little ice cream you know give
me that chocolate joint on a cone he's
like i can't serve you without a mask
and i said really he's like yeah you
have to buy one i was like [__] and if i
wasn't stoned i wouldn't have cared
because i really wanted that [__] ice
cream so i had to buy a mask and then he
hands me the ice cream cone
and i i just assume
i take the mask off and i assume i can
eat it because it's a [__] ice cream
shop no
he said you have to put your mask back
on i was like oh we gotta stop this [__]
i'm so glad it's over it's [__] over
it's [__] over once i got it in my
mind it was over like i'm like
the fear has been lifted we survived i
had 20 [__] friends that had it i got
a friend up in northbrook and i had it
three [__] times
damn three times and he said that that
person needs to eat an apple they need
to he needs to get a [__] immune
system because you know to get it three
[__] oh he's hanging out the wrong
goddamn places yeah where's he going
who's he licking he sounds vulnerable
but at the same time you know
i i don't know what was going on i'm not
gonna even get into it it's just i'm
just happy to see you but it's funny you
look fantastic you really do i'm trying
i love the silver you're a silver fox oh
yeah it got silvery
you look rich as [__] yeah rich yeah
good
rich rich and what [__] fat cells
not yours
so good you really do you look like you
own a yacht that's the kind of face you
got right now i'm [__] sleeping
i'm drinking a lot of water
i'm not talking to agents
that keeps you young when you don't have
to listen to that [__]
uh
i'm just enjoying time with my [__]
daughter you know for a year it took me
a year to
acclimate to this type of life
and then i realized i haven't had this
life since i was 16.
you know yeah i'm joey i'm running and
gunning every day you know we're running
since my mother died
i didn't have a day of peace i was out
at night
so this is the first time i've had peace
and [__] 40 years so
i just feel like to you
what's it feel like to me yeah what's
peace feel like if you could describe it
to someone who's never had it
you know what peace is to me that isn't
much to people my daughter my daughter
comes down at night at like 10 30. she
waits for my wife to go upstairs and
falls asleep
then she sneaks downstairs and we watch
a cooking show
and then we'll watch something else for
a half hour and i'll send her up at 11
30.
but while we're sitting in that well i'm
sitting in my old man chair and she's
laying on the couch
i'm watching the cartoon or whatever the
[__] the cooking challenge but i'm
really not watching it
i'm just basking
in the joy of watching tv with my
daughter
at 10 30 at night talking about it we're
gonna go upstairs and get a snack
we got any girl scout cookies left yeah
i'll go get one you know she went up and
got a s'mores from me and her
that to me is something i always wanted
to do
you know what i'm saying like that's
what i always have to do so that's
really beautiful and that's the
equivalent of beauty to me that's
me going to the softball games me
driving out of kickboxing
are people drive now because you you're
in jersey now
are people
like the locals coming up to you or are
people giving you space like how are you
finding that you know being the
celebrity in town no it's 50 50.
i've been here for a long time now so i
went you know i got out of the car i
went right to the [__] field
and saw people and got the initial
reactions from them now they just wave
at me and say hello i'm part of a
community now
that's nice so they don't look at me as
a dirty comic or anything you know
they just think i'm retired or i quit
i'm not doing it for right now i don't
know what they think but
it's a nice place i got jimmy florentine
around the corner yeah the other day and
i thanked him i said thank you the other
day just saturday we were talking he was
in florida
and i go jimmy i want to thank you for
[__] turning me on to this [__]
community and he took me to all his
places so he opened up the door for me
at the vitamin store at the gym you know
you got to hook up on glucosamine oh
yeah that's funny you say glucosamine
yeah yeah
the health food store i go to
the guy
i can't even describe him to he's a
friend of jimmy's
he's this guy that he's done everything
in that health food store
do you understand he's eating every pill
every craton
every [__] quick trip cbd
every time i go in there this guy's got
a [__] new idea but he's solid he
hooked me up with the acupuncturist i
mean the guy's been there
for close to 50 years
his mother owned that health food store
before so all you got to do is go in
there hooks me up with a vitamin
my covert package
the [__] cbd delta eights and delta
knights get those delta eights and delta
nines that's the only way to fly these
days baby he's got everything in there
and i just go to him and say i need a
vitamin for an over 50 year old man
he's like if you're a 55 i'd give you
this but since you're 59
i'm gonna give you that he knows his
[__]
that's awesome so
i take a nutrient every day like
vitamins and when i swallow them it's
like swallowing 22 black dicks a dead
one and a ukrainian one it tastes so bad
that multivitamin and when i
do the first burp i almost pass out from
the taste of that [__] multivitamin
but you know what i handle it and then
you piss yellow all day i piss at night
it glows in the [__] dark my wife saw
it the other night she's like you gotta
go to the hospital no no no no i gotta
take this [__] multivitamin so she
read it she goes jesus christ no wonder
you're pissing that color this has
everything in there plus like a hundred
percent
so whatever your body doesn't utilize a
glow stick yeah you just [__] uh pee
the [__]
out am i gonna do i got [__] problems
you know what i'm saying i'm just trying
to keep it together i'm smoking good
dope
yeah you now you you and i spoke and
you were saying how you sort of evolved
your smoking habits a little bit yeah i
had to when i got here because of
anxiety and other things so i switched
it around
and i just what did you switch it to
um i didn't smoke in the i think i gave
it up for about eight months
i really went under my threshold no
edibles no nothing
and then i started a huge tolerance
break
yes it is yes it is and it was [__]
much needed
and it was very good and i'll tell you
what i think i'm gonna do another
tolerance break here for about 90 days
no maybe 90 days is all you need
i don't think i could do [__] eight
months again that was
a lucky thing i was withdrawing i was i
had the pain pills my knee surgery so it
was kind of easy to do it you know i
don't think i could do but three months
feels good i don't listen right now
jessica
if i smoke
eight bong hits a day that's too much
i haven't rolled the joint in much it's
just not worth it the weed we get
you'll need to roll joints you're just
throwing [__] weed away so
yeah
you look so beautiful you look like
you've matured what's been going on in
your life talk to me i rested i've been
sleeping more for one i mean you're
talking about sleep like i don't know if
it's like an age thing but damn if i
don't get a certain number of hours of
sleep
i can't function in society i can't
function mentally i've been sleeping
more
um i've been getting i got a little
action past couple weeks and
i just kind of feel like you know we
were sort of talking about relationships
and stuff in la and how difficult it is
to date in this town
i had this conversation with my sister
um i kind of feel like
i don't really
you know i'm almost 40. i'm 39
and i don't have that drive to be in a
white dress i don't have that drive
or desire to
have a child right now and i know people
are probably like oh you you better
[__] hurry up look
that mentality
worked for back in the day now people
are healthier we're living longer so the
idea of a woman having a child at 40
early 40s
it seems maybe taboo to some people but
because of how we're living now it's
more possible and probable my wife had
hers at 44.
see
and
scary
scary for sure it's scary you really you
know the
the time over 40 the more years over
like janet jackson had a kid at 50. do
you think you could have that kid no
because you don't have 20 [__]
dollars to play pay for a [__] van
soon and a nurse and a witch doctor you
know you got to have 30 [__] people
to have a kid when you're [__] 50
gyms and the doctor has to come over
every day and check your [__] scent
and your oxygen
so she had the kid but it cost her a lot
of [__] money
yeah i mean the older you get the more
expensive it definitely gets that's a
really good point
loud i don't i don't have the drive for
any of it i don't
i don't know if quarantine changed it
for me or losing my mom changed it for
me but
i feel like
i'm i don't want to settle for
anything so
i i just sort of feel like singlehood is
is where i'm at right now in life and
i'm feeling comfortable with that
see society puts all this pressure on
women to be [__] married
and then women take that pressure they
[__] don't know what to do their
friends are getting married your sister
got married
this jerk off got married to the richest
guy in the world he's having a wedding
on a boat and here you are in albany
doing jokes for a bunch of [__] you
know
guts is there so
it [__] weighs on you when you look
around and see what's going on other
people's life but i gotta tell you what
you're doing that other people aren't
doing you're living your life
yeah that's true
i'm exploring and traveling and
creating things you know those things
become your family those things become
your children those things sort of
take up residence in a different way in
your life
and you know i i think like also going
through like you know you've experienced
so much in your life so i know you can
relate to all different types of losses
and trauma and stuff like that
it really has made me realize
that
it's okay to say no to [__] it's okay to
not want to put up with
bare minimum [__] and i i until i
think until i lost my mom
it i didn't realize how much [__] i was
putting up with it was like i was blind
to it and now i look back and like why
was i even
giving any
any sort of
attention to those toxic things in
people so it feels good in that sense to
be free of
feeling like i need to accommodate every
single person in this world that
previously i would have given
entertainment to now i don't how long
has your mom been passed away for it now
it was a year in november
yes a year and a half
seven years
right now
how are you feeling
i feel lighter for the first time in a
long time i feel
more present and i didn't even realize
it and i wonder if you've gone through
these experiences or times in your life
where you don't even know you're
depressed you have no idea you're just
like
going through
the motions and
just surviving and then until you get
out of that
you go oh [__]
that was depression
that functioning from a point of
survival and
you know not being fully present and
just sort of grasping at everything is
what i was doing and i didn't until
last november the year anniversary of my
mom
until then did i realize i was depressed
for like a full
i don't know i think on and off for
years my dad died in 2018 and i feel
like i've just been sort of
surviving and coming up for air since
2017 when he was sick because he was
sick
and then he died and you know with
dealing with the death and loss it's so
heavy and it's such a revolving evolving
process
then quarantine hit and then my mom died
so i feel like i've just been in this
like
[__] washed cycle this emotional wash
cycle where any time i've come up for
air i'm put back down and now i feel
like i am
breathing out i'm out of the the
the
tumultuous
part of it all
so i feel like more present just
i feel like it's the first time where i
know who i am
that's what it feels like to me i feel
really calm really present
and because of that similarly to you
i i'm
smoking less i do love weed but i'm
smoking less but i also like do edibles
i microdose on psilocybin and i've done
that through the entirety of you know
the past four years so i do have ways of
using things and medicines that make me
that help me feel balanced but i'm using
a lot less of those things and i think
that is definitely indicative of me
feeling a little bit more grounded like
my feet are planted and not like i'm
kicking in water anymore
so you're grieving both your mom and
your dad and you know what this takes
a long time maybe that's why
you're not in a rush to look for a
[__] man or have a child because you
have no she got no grandmother the kid's
not going to have a grandmother on this
side yes i'm saying so
um
i think about that a lot yeah right now
you know you just had two serious deaths
and it's weird you didn't get a chance
to grieve one and then the other one
died because grieving doesn't take two
[__] weeks people have no idea
that grieving doesn't take two weeks
grieving
hides at that funeral
he hides when the casket goes in the
grave
and it makes you think you're okay it
makes you think you're okay like you
even start going what the [__]
my mother could have died twice and i
don't even miss her it's [__] weird
like for me i gotta tell you this is the
most disturbing story of my life
[__] the kidnapping [__] bottles of
people [__]
[__] kidnap robin hookers i think the
most disturbing
thing i ever
ever ever
[__] went through was my mom died
november 8th right so i was cool all of
november
i was like damn i don't even miss this
[__]
i mean i miss a [__] cooking
but i really don't miss him
then i went to see judas priest november
29th and the war came out that weekend
so the wall kind of took my mind away
like it picked up where i should have
started missing her after two weeks
but the wall took me through the whole
month of december and i remember that i
was [__] hating christmas
i didn't even want to think of what
christmas felt like right yes
christmas eve came
nothing
christmas day came
nothing i was like [__]
i'm gonna go talk to a priest because i
don't even think i love my mother
i mean it was horrible what i felt it
was like just another day christmas i
thought i was gonna break down and
no you know when it hit me
like a night before new year's i was at
my friend's house we were having a party
going warmed up for new year's the night
before new year's just a little warm up
and that song came on mother by pink
floyd on side one
and i had to listen to it you know
my mother dying i had put it on put it
on put it on but for some reason this
night
i couldn't breathe i went outside dog
and i just started puking and crying and
the puking carried me all the way home i
was like on 70th street i had to walk to
39th street
it's [__] 10 degrees is 11. you know
and i'm walking puking and crying and
the tears would freeze on my face
and i walked she was on a hill a
cemetery on the hill and i remember that
i jumped the fence
because i didn't believe she was dead
i was like she ain't dead they're
playing a trick on me even though you
saw her at the wake for four [__]
days even though you saw them close the
lid
even though you saw them [__] put her
in the hole
i ran to the cemetery i tried to dig her
out with my hands the [__] concrete
was frozen
and i remember i caught myself and i was
just babbling crying like the tears
saliva boogies coming out of my nose
i jumped the fence and i ran to my house
because i used to [__] always go
maybe she came home maybe
i don't know maybe she got lost on the
bus
i don't [__] know and i would sit
there and wait for her at night on the
stairs
and i actually one night i even knocked
on the door
i believe it and i was like all right
i'm going [__] crazy i can't do this
anymore and and that
i've always remembered that night like
it's [__] tattooed in my [__] soul
how much pain i was in and after that it
just ran the pain just didn't go away
for years
yeah
it's like a roller coaster oh my god it
was horrible
and it would go away and then at night
it would come back because you were busy
the night you're busy all day you're
like i got over her death and all of a
sudden you walk in your house you take a
shower you're alone
and it [__] lands on you like a
[__] hammer
it sure does the night time's the worst
time and then i was doing drugs and i
was you know
mugging people whatever the [__] i was
doing
then the deep
uh
the deep
guilt came in 84.
and that's how i ended up homeless in a
[__] park living in a rocket ship
because the pain was unbearable
and then i was okay i was leveled but
42 years later
there's still a little bit of pain and
it's like i tell people when their
parents are like oh you're gonna make it
but it's like food
anything you eat from now on it's not
gonna have salt on it that's the way
your life feels like it's missing the
salt
and i've always said that so grieving
takes [__] years
years it's a long time and you might
agree with your friends first yeah you
might grieve your mom first and come to
terms with it but one day you might have
a cocktail to smoke a joint and also you
open up your dads
and now you gotta agree with that
[__] you're like what the [__]
how am i thinking of him he died three
years before my mom so
grieving is a [__] mental nightmare
it is it's like um it feels like boot
camp for your soul and
it's so individualized you know there's
like that cooler ross
method of or the stages of grief but i
for me
you know the stages obviously aren't
linear and
there's other things that occur
that happen that aren't even
a part of what is supposed to happen to
you
and the other thing that was [__] up
for us is because of
covid and a lot of people experience
this we could have a funeral so we
didn't get to go through that like
normal tradition
of
which is a healthy
process i think
to see them dead to see like you said
see them be buried see them in the
casket like
one of the reasons for that is so that
we can identify them as being dead and
having
some levity with that and connection
with that helps us understand that they
are in fact dead
and even for you
you know it was unbelievable for you and
that's how strong grief is but we didn't
have that so there was a real the
disbelief time for me lasted
for months i was like where is this this
[__] isn't calling me back
where is this [__] she doesn't want to
go to marshall's and date she don't want
a day drink and go to marshalls why what
she's she's got a life now that's
part of me was like crazy
it's really crazy how you forget your
mind it's like the man said the mind
playing tricks on you
your mind
really [__] plays true and once you
go through that [__] you also learn
that what rambo said was true
the [__] mind is the most
unique thing in the world [__] computers
your mind could do so many [__]
things it's like when you don't want to
do something all sudden you start
getting tired or
man i don't feel good that's your
[__] mind playing games with you you
know when you read the art of war
not the one by sun tzu but the other guy
that talks about writing have you ever
read that one the war of art or whatever
the war of art
they talk about that how your mind you
know
[__] i forgot what i was gonna say to
you i gotta stop smoking this [__]
reef no you were saying how your your
mind is a thing that creates everything
and how your mind is like the most
powerful thing and it's you're right
like what literally it's the same saying
is if you believe it you can achieve it
what that's saying is
if you can create or
muster up something in your mind it
becomes your reality our thoughts become
our world and it's it's wild how
anything within that can sort of create
a reality whether it's a
reality that's close to what's actually
going on or us thinking our parents are
still alive
we're thinking those thoughts and we
might seem crazy to other people but
that is our reality that's our truth in
that moment because our brain isn't you
know it's it's so powerful that it
creates whatever that
world is
it really is like your your mind is
unbelievable
you know i was reading about that new
diet
oh god
no i'm just reading about it some guy
was talking about on instagram
they had something and i said let me
look this thing up and it's a diet
unlike like weight watchers or whatever
it attacks your mental
wow you wanted to this diet the first 20
days or something there's a lot of
journaling
a lot of walking 9 000 steps a day [__]
like that but it teaches you how to eat
all over again
but it's psychological and it's pretty
interesting i was thinking about joining
up and seeing what it's about i'm just
not in the mood to start another [__]
diet i'm happy with
white watches if
it works but
it just goes to show you that if the
mind can
which
the mind can conceive the body can
achieve yes so it all starts with your
mind
it really does it's like you can create
your own placebo effect it's so weird
how i did a podcast last year about
turning the switch
how
some people it's harder for
some people turn the switch on quicker
than others if i put two people
on the same open mic and watch them and
they both do the same amount of sets
every night
one guy is gonna naturally be ahead of
the other guy you know i'm saying like
one
guy and then the one guy catches up over
in time the guy that got ahead his cat
dies he doesn't go off for a week and
then the other guy comes in and does the
sets and catch ups to him
but it's just really interesting how
we could start at the same time and we
could both have different results but we
both get to the same destination
yeah i'm saying like yes the destination
is the comedy store every night on stage
that's where i want to be
so when you write down that goal that's
where it starts i want to be at the
comedy store four nights a week next to
bill bird next to jessica may paluso
next to joe rogan
and the more you write that that's why i
always say i like writing goals because
the power of the pen the power of the
pen will take you there without you even
[__] knowing
it's so weird even now i write little
goals and i go to the gym and boom three
weeks later i'm achieving them and i
thought i can you know like
being able to roll 20 minutes in a row
you know on their own machine whatever
the [__] like i always do stupid [__]
like that you know i started walking
on the treadmill so you got to like
[__] put it up to 10 and run up the
hill and die and then switch it but you
got to change it up on your mind you
know it's so weird how the mind and i
gotta be honest with you
and people aren't gonna believe when i
tell you this
with comedy i did a lot of [__]
meditating and i had to see myself there
first
like i would go to a theater with joe
rogan and go
wow
i'm never gonna be able to play this
[__] theater
and then i would go see you're catching
yourself talking [__]
yep you have to leave here saying you'll
be back on your own one [__] day when
you leave the theater have your hand
touch the wall or whatever then go home
that night and write it
i want to play this [__] theater when
i open when i used to work for joe
and i would go to those theaters i
[__] wrote those theaters names down
and i think
i like the 31 theaters he took me to i
went to 27 of them on my own wow
you know and i always a lot of people
don't know about that little secret that
i did on my own just to
prove to myself that this is where you
came at one time as an opener
and now you came back here as a
headliner
yeah it's it's you know you're basically
applying a lot of really
advanced
strategy for yourself you know
visualizing and visualization is huge
for achieving goals it's probably one of
the most important aspects of it and
writing it down i do the same thing
i do the same exact thing mainly because
i my i have 80d like you know actually
diagnosed add not just when people say
oh i have ocd i have a d i really do and
it's v it's a struggle
um and one of the things that helps me
with all my chaotic thoughts is writing
them all down
and i realize the same thing where you
you start to write things down and then
you're like
it's really it's really important to
track yourself
otherwise we're just ships with no
direction we're literally just floating
around in this [__] ocean not not
doing anything not going to any port not
visiting anybody not catching any
[__] fish you're just a ship in the
ocean doing jack [__] you're rudderless
you're rudderless and and it's funny
because when i got into comedy
i knew nothing you know i didn't have a
coach to tell you so everything i did i
figured out on my own and the little
things were to write
the date
the name of the venue
you know if you were a feature a
headliner or emcee
i wish i would have done that and i
would write out my set
and then
but i would be honest with myself like
when i get home from a show
before i even did a line of coke
before i rolled the joint before i peed
before i took a [__]
it was a discipline that i opened up
this notebook and would write down my
sets
so i did uh
the houston laptop
i did okay
i could have done better
would you write that down yes and i
wouldn't write the reasoning like i
would never say the audience sucked
i would always put i need to work harder
and then i would always put the material
that i used
the key jokes so when i come back
i don't use those jokes again
and it's funny when i lived in boulder i
started that and in boulder i had a
20-month
20-set a month goal you were not gonna
hit it there wasn't 20 sets
there was no way colorado yeah when i
was an open mic unless somebody took you
on the road and i wasn't ready for that
unless you're entertaining a
field of weed
yeah no i would go to like
i would follow like a [__] uh what's
that [__] that miley cyrus's dad
invented
the whoopee song whatever the [__] my
icky breaky heart remember they used to
dance that [__] dance in my breaky
breaky heart a bunch of rednecks with
boots and hats on and a [__] boss
shuffling
dog sunday nights i would follow a line
dancing class
there was comedy at eight after a
[__] hour line dancing class
you had to throw i asked rednecks out
because that's the way the club did it
and then they do
country dancing that night at nine
[__] horrible
you know monday i was at a [__]
australian bar and they put us in the
back in the rehearsal room like the
rooms had padding and [__] on it and you
had to close the door and you couldn't
breathe in there people were on stage
turning purple because it was like a
bank vault and they would only see 16
people
tuesdays i had the comedy works
wednesday at club 56
or the [__] elvis in person hit his
room he was a chef and then he was an
elvis impersonator he weighed like 500
pounds so i had to open for him and then
wait for him to do his set so i could go
back up there and greet him good night
nobody knows i'd rather take it up the
ass than had that job now in hindsight
that i think about it
seeing an elvis impersonator is [__]
suicide like that's what elvis like
listen i'm not you could either do 20
years in jail
or sit through a set of an elvis
impersonator with a knife next to you if
you can make it you'll [__] walk free
out of this [__] prison
thursday i had el torito
the mexican joint burbank where the
[__] you get poisoned in there the
food was horrible
cry out of your [__] el torito was so
[__] bad
like it was holding on in 94 and 95 but
el torito was in burbank across from
where
[__] does the tonight show you know jay
leno
it's good next to it was
whatever the [__] he's doing now he's
got a coffee shop in his garage go [__]
yourself you got two million [__]
cars
[__] go get a ticket somewhere
yeah that place was where boston market
is now and burbank
[__] love a boston market i don't
know why not boston oh [__] boston
market oh that place is disgusting they
give you you cry out of your butt
it used to be really good when it first
[__] started you remember the lines
from boston market everybody was eating
chicken but what happened to boston
market was people started saying whoa
we can make our own chickens for 6.99
so every supermarket started making
chickens so boston market [__]
i think there's eight of them left
they're and they're all like off of
throughway yeah like that's the worst
food to eat while you're in transit oh
there was a town put on a [__] diaper
and my daughter liked it my daughter
liked the one in burbank and she would
ask for a macaroni and cheese restaurant
it was [__] awful
and i would have to sit there with her
and eat that [__] pigeon meat because
that's a [__] pigeon
oh [__] horrible wait can i can i ask
you a question
i remember you saying something one time
that along with back to what you're
saying about writing the date and the
place the location do you also have a
notebook
where you've written down everyone
you've ever performed with
well the that notebook same we'll have
that on there
and so it would be the the list the
lineup that see that to me is so
interesting to see
you know i have a couple of those uh
like flyers and things and
it's interesting to see who stuck with
it because it's it's very it's out of
like 10 people like two have actually
broken through
you know so it's interesting to see
those names that have
stuck it for the long haul in this
industry and who has actually achieved
an
you know
a a nice amount of success where it's
all they do there's only one guy
that's doing real comedy from when i was
doing comedy in 92 93
94 95 in denver that's a kid by the name
of jimmy abay the mexican guy i'm 59
he's got to be about 62. hard-working
guy just never left colorado he had it
too easy you know he had a bunch of gigs
during the week and
you know every time a concert would come
in they'd call him great guy
but i thought about that too i thought
about the [__] guys i started with
and where they are today and
none of them are around they're not even
in the comedy game no more wow it's a
tough it's a tough industry i know we've
talked about this i'm sure people have
listened to conversations about how hard
comedy is but it really is a weird
thing it's it's a
it's a difficult
job to get good at or career it's a
difficult career to pursue because
you know you've got to branch out
like even you you've branched out into
other things and you've done a ton of
acting and
you know podcasting and all of that like
do you out of all the things that you've
done in your career
do you see view comedy as like your only
the only thing you really enjoy doing i
know you haven't you sort are off the
road for a while now but
out of everything you've done is that
the thing that you love the most or do
you enjoy making films as well in my
life i mean listen
i love comedy and for the young comics
that are watching this show let me tell
you something
whether you want to be a comedy writer a
[__]
whatever
give stand up a world for one year i
don't want you to be a pro with it i
don't want you to get good at it
just make a commitment before you get
into any field camera work
any field you wanted directing producing
go do stand up for a year just go once a
week talk to them guys learn the mind of
a stand-up because that's the best mind
in the industry
i'm very proud to say yes i love
stand-up comedy
stand-up comedy took me out of the
[__] world of criminality i fell in
love with it was all i ever knew
and the one thing about me is i really
[__] respected it like that's where
mine and joe rogan's connection comes
from we have nothing in common
i'm a criminal he's a [__] genius you
know what i'm saying
we have nothing in common but our common
thing is our love
and respect and dedication for stand up
i would have died for it but it's also
it's the ground floor for any
entertainment career
because
when you do stand up one of the greatest
things i ever watched in my life was
roseanne barr
on that [__] show what's larry king
larry king yeah
right right what what happened i have a
vague memory well she did the one
episode she was talking about how oprah
kidnapped her and put receptors in her
brain
to steal her ideas so when you say that
you're like [__] roseanne what are
you talking about but then all very
valid he asked her a question he goes
listen why did you throw
all the people from abc the top brass
out of the christmas party
one year and she goes listen
i was dealing with a bunch of [__]
idiots i love roseanne for this
i love roseanne for what she did for me
by saying this
she goes in hollywood we deal with a
bunch of [__] idiots
they went to college
they watched two movies
they're not us
we dove ourselves into this and then she
made this statement she goes when you do
comedy
you're the director you're the producer
you're the writer you're the sound tech
you're everything
it breaks down into all those categories
that you could grow from
so she goes when they told me that they
wanted me to beat the cosby show out
i thought about it and i go i was going
to ask for help
but i didn't need help i knew how to
beat him out
by being [__] funny
so she goes i i fired all the writers
they gave me because they didn't know
[__] about [__] and i hired stand-up
writers and yes regular writers
and friends people who knew me and they
were writing the episodes you know and i
know half the guys she hired and it was
[__] it was really good for comedy
you know it was really good to take
these guys and take them through a set
and help them [__] punch up scripts
and that's how she beat cosby
she knocked cosby out of thursday night
because she said she went back to her
comedic roots
and if you think about it how many times
are you down how many times have you
called me and said i can't get no help i
can't get this and after a week as a
stand-up comic you know you go [__] help
i don't need that [__] help i'm
taking this into my own [__] hands
and you put it together better than they
were gonna do with the agents and i did
that i did that with the longer shot i
did that with amer when they told me
they didn't want to see me for the
longest shot i said [__] you that's what
they told you and you accepted it
they're not gonna tell me that he's
gonna get two comedic actors
what adam sandler needs is a [__]
kick-ass comic for that [__] role and
you don't believe in me as much as you
do and i understand that but guess what
i believe in me more than you believe in
me so i'm putting that audition on paper
and i'm sending it to adam sandler and i
got that [__] movie and that's what
comics do
we figure out a way
and we always go back to us nobody can
help you nobody's gonna help you sell
tickets
nobody's gonna help you write material
nobody's gonna help you book comedy gigs
nobody's gonna do [__] or you have to
assume that
so at the end of all your crying and all
your woe is me you go
[__] you i'm going to take matters into
my own hands that's why i put auditions
on tape jessica
when all these [__] were
telling me to go on the road on
wednesdays because you had to do radio
on thursdays i would say no i do a
podcast on wednesday night
and someday this podcast is gonna
[__] help me out and now that i'm 59
and i don't want to do stand-up
that's why i work those wednesday nights
to build a [__] podcast and to build
trust with an audience even though the
agents wanted oh they want you to come
in on wednesday night for what to do
some stupid radio on thursday i don't
need to [__] do if they want me to
come and do radio i'll tell you what
cancel the week and let's find the week
when you don't need radio and they would
go okay don't worry about it
come on in so that's the thing about
stand-ups not the thing about us is
human beings
they're not gonna help you nobody's
gonna help you
assume you have to think like that
exactly nobody's gonna help you look at
the situation
and write three different scenarios on
how you can help that situation how can
i become a better comic i could write
more i could perform more
you know i can hang out with doug
stanhope and learn more i can hang out
with [__] jessamy there's three
different variables here i'll put nine
months in to see if my i go on a triple
run
for [__] a year you want to get
really good go for a [__] triple run
for a year
do each of those rooms twice and then
come back and see me you'll be a [__]
powerhouse so oh yeah
i don't know what you're talking about i
changed
you know i i have reached out to you for
help so many different times and
just from
you know
that whole conversation what you're just
talking about like you have to assume
that no one's going to help you has been
the most vital
piece of advice for me not just in my
career but in in life
becoming really self-sufficient and
becoming savvy and and realizing you
have everything inside of you and the
resources you need
to get [__] done
and no one's gonna do it for you and the
longer you think that the longer you're
gonna wait and nothing's gonna get done
and and
beyond that
whatever they tell you isn't gospel
whatever agents
say or or whatever anyone says
that's
that's not the way it is it's the way
they know it to be
and
one phrase that i can't [__] stand in
the industry as well that's the way it's
done
okay well at some point somebody came up
with an idea that hadn't been done
before and you know what it [__]
worked
don't tell me that's not that's the way
it's done have a little bit of gumption
have a little bit of
fire under you and that's that's what i
think
it makes the comedians different the
ones that succeed and break through
there's a fire there's a relentless
ambition there's like a not accepting no
mentality and
and this almost like a blind confidence
especially when you're first starting
out
you're like [__] you no i'll make it a
yes somehow like what you're saying like
they're not they don't want to see me
and i love that you were like that's
what they told you
that's how you're selling they told you
you bought that [__] line like
[__] uh tony did from sosa i was
watching that last night scarface when
he tells him you bought that line you
know you bought that [__] line
listen this is the way i look at it a
wise man once told me his name was rick
dukeman god rest his soul a casting
director's job
is to book that film
she wants to tell you that she's going
to search high and low for the right
actor but when she takes the job she
already knows who she's looking for or
three people or four people
if i looked at a job
and i told my agent i was right for it
he said no i would [__] submit myself
i didn't give a [__] what he said
and maybe six out of 10 times i was
right that means i'm betting 60 percent
they have a limitation they're scared
and really now today they're very scared
when i got into the business i used to
walk into my manager's office and hear
him cursing [__] out
i mean tremendously yes he's out of the
business now because i think he cursed
out one too many [__] but
he fought for you he believed in you
these [__] today look what they
did to calallen and dalia and all these
guys by an accusation
the agents dropped them so all those
years you took that [__] money and
now you drop me go [__] yourself now
look at the liam bill cat and brian
count they're all jumping up and down
there's no more rapes there was never a
[__] rape there was never
but you guys bought into a [__]
allegation so you let all these
[__] go when i saw that [__] in
the business i'm like these agents are
pieces of [__]
and in time we're going to learn how to
avoid these [__]
comics are going to go you know what i'm
going to get an attorney
i don't even want to go on a movie or tv
i just want to go on the road i just got
to get a [__] attorney to call i love
my attorney yeah that a lot of people
don't jeff cohen yeah jeff cohen's a
[__] savage one of the original
goonies and [__]
[Laughter]
my attorney truffle shuffles
[__] try and [__] me over he he
was so good
i trust he he's just so communicative
and and and
honestly has been a perfect example has
been in the industry as an actor
you know in goonies and goonies
he is a cultural icon
and
because of that understands how to
package things and understands what to
look for and what to ask for and um
after my dad passed away i started
writing about it and and during him
being sick i was writing about it and
it became this thing and i said i think
i want to turn this into a screenplay or
something and we ended up
partnering with a production company
and
i wrote a screenplay treatment for it
jeff didn't like the deal
he said you know i don't like this deal
for you i know you want to do this and
and you want to turn this into
a movie and i and i respect that but
this isn't a good deal for you
you know
most people would just take the money
and go yeah go ahead make make make the
thing but he knew it mattered to me he
knew he's like you know this is
something that is your story and you
should write it the way you want it done
not hand it to somebody and have it be
turned into something else
and i'll i'll always be indebted to him
for that because then it made me take a
minute and sit with it and go oh he's
right i need to turn this into a
different piece of art this has to be
formulated more and really spent some
time on instead of turned over to
somebody else to write
my experience
you know because i wanted to write the
screenplay i wanted to write the script
and they weren't willing to partner with
me and i was like well
then i i ca
how am i gonna hand this to you you want
me to hit
my dad's story to you and i can't
[__] help write it
are you crazy i wrote it so good you
wanna buy it you should be smart enough
to know that i'm good enough to write it
out
and jeff was like we gotta go
and it's it's important like you know
you're right about the lawyer thing like
having a lawyer that's tough and savvy
and willing to go to bat for you
that's one of the main things you need
you know early on i reached out and
connected with dane cook and it's one of
the things he told me too do you need a
really good lawyer
start there start with a really solid
savvy lawyer and maybe a manager but a
lawyer is somebody who will protect you
on all angles of this system all angles
all angles i'm my life's a lot better
not my lawyer's florentine's brother
[__] uncle dude that's some jersey i
love that and that [__] does not
play [__] games jessamy
do you write your mother and father a
letter once a month
oh my god
no
i tell you it helped me a lot
wow i got a notebook of letters i write
my mother once a month
your granddaughter's doing great
she reminds me of your cousin miriam
yeah
that's beautiful that has helped me so
[__] much over the years and
especially after i had mercy
because the hardest pain i think after i
had mercy was
not having my mother around for her
she's an ordinary she's an extraordinary
little [__] girl
that i wish my mother got to be around
because my mother's all she need to push
her over the other side mercy's like
a wild woman but she just needs that
last push
and uh
it's great but yeah start writing a
letter to your mom on the first
that's a really good idea and your
father just a letter
if you want you could put in the
envelope
and go through the process you know like
yeah but if you don't just put it in a
notebook
that's a really great thing
it'll [__] uh
it'll make you fall in love again
trust me i'm telling you yeah i believe
that that's the thank you that's a
really you know i've always
through this whole process i've looked
for ways to heal and have taken up you
know i meditate almost every single
morning i meditated every single morning
after my mom died and for a year
and um it changed the game for me it
really
gave me a place to
put my emotions and gave me a place to
have a little bit of space to breathe
and
start the day that way for me has
been vital to my survival
and journaling and all of that honestly
meditating
writing
and working out if i miss one of those
i'm off
i'm a little off i'm not
i i don't i'm not as intentional
and i used to think they were such
woo-woo things to do oh you journal oh
[__] cool bro what do you write dear
abby and and now that i actually do it i
go oh okay
there's something to this there's
something to this because like we said
the mind
you have like a hundred thousand
thoughts a day
that's exhausting
that's tiresome and we know especially
you and i as being artists and
performers they're not all [__]
positive no
not like a peanut gallery dog you know
for every positive thought
you got to get a negative thought and
you got to get it dark though
you know so when i get a dark thought
like hey
we won't pay attention to it you know
like i want to take somebody's eye out
or something i won't pay attention to
that thought but guess what i also came
up with the thought to add music to the
pa you know what i'm saying like i'll
think of something positive and
move forward you got any weeks you got
any tour dates coming up anything yeah i
actually do i'm forgotten i'm going back
out on the road i've been off the road
from for months now i'm going to be at
the kansas city improv for
st patrick's day weekend with cody woods
great club a great great comic he's a
local guy from there
yeah what else you got going on
i'm going on tour with my other podcast
it's a patreon exclusive pod for now
it's called girl and it's with my friend
carly aquilino and her and i are going
on the road we're gonna be in a bunch of
cities
um nashville and
chicago new york we're hitting all the
you know the the coveted hot spots
um
in my podcast sharp tongue still going
strong i'm so glad i stuck with it you
know
somebody that was on my team a while
back told me maybe i should give it up
and
it just goes back to that conversation
about having
faith in what you do and knowing you're
worth it and knowing you're good and now
you know it's
allowed me to do whatever i want to do
now like i don't i'm not there's no more
feast or famine like because i put more
effort into it and
really stuck it out like that's
now the podcast is taking care of of a
majority of of my expenses and
that's because people are listening and
enjoying it
and if i had not
doubled down on it and cut it off like i
i can't even imagine where i'd be so
you know it's all about listening to
that positive voice in your head knowing
you're [__] worth it and not
listening to people who've never done
what you do tell you how to do what
you're doing
it's [__] crazy when they try to tell
you and you're like get the [__] out of
my face
what the [__] do you know i get up at 5
45 in the morning to do a [__]
podcast and you're gonna come over here
with your [__] story when are you on
the east coast again money in point
pleasant again
uh you know i i owe them a weekend i owe
them a summer weekend at point pleasant
new jersey
and beach haven um i don't know probably
this summer maybe summer or fall uncle
vinnie call dino and uncle vincent yeah
i have to i gotta come out there i told
you to call them i'll call them today
that's a great little club it's one show
friday
one show saturday that's what i'm
talking about you could you're in the
east coast you come over and crash two
nights i got an extra bedroom go to your
next gig
save some money yeah just give me a call
you know i love you to death
i love you too and i i honestly
you checking up on me throughout the
quarantine made me feel like i had
family and i appreciate that amen
forget about my [__] girls you know
that [__] are savages in fact i
even called you and said what's that
thing with that little skinny boney ass
out i don't want to
see that bony ass of yours ever again
for years you were keeping it together
now you're flaunting
showing that ass
i don't know what the [__] going on
that's why i asked you if you have put
your grieving away yet because when i
seen that little skinny bony ass like
what the [__] is she thinking that's my
sister showing that ass cute little ass
but
you got to put some weight on that
[__] you know what i'm saying
you want johnny black to hit it with
your dick you know johnny black hits it
with your dick at the end he'll break
the cheek you gotta
you gotta put some mambo in that
[__] you know what i'm saying
i show up back in the day with the cuban
aggro i break your [__] hip
oh you crazy [__]
keep me posted i love you god bless you
and if you need something you call okay
i know that i'm happy you did this today
don't forget that letter to mom and dad
on the first i'm gonna [__] do it i
am when we hang up and i'm gonna hit up
um
dino too okay i'll call dino too i love
you at all my heart thank you for coming
on the joint and
whenever you wanna come on and talk some
[__] i like to come on the sharp dunk so
keep me posted
all right you dirty [__] all right
i love you take that boney ass off the
[__] tv screen
okay bye bye
all right you bad [__] uh we
talked a lot about losing somebody
because uh that was the topic that we
were talking about that the last couple
weeks on the phone what do we want to
discuss you know a lot of people lost uh
people during the pandemic
so uh i know you're feeling weird and uh
i don't want you to grieve alone i
wanted to break the grieving process to
you and throw you some ideas
if you're grieving somebody and uh
you're really missing that person i told
this to another friend of mine that uh
her father died a while back and she was
having a hard time therapy and i go no
no no no
write your parents your brother your
sister-in-law
you know i lost my sister-in-law during
the pandemic i write her a letter once
every other month i started about two
months ago
but my mom i've been writing letters to
for about
15 years
and my father i've been writing letters
for about 10 years now
so every month on the first which was uh
yesterday
this week i did it on monday night just
wrote him a short letter what's going on
how i'm feeling and it helps man it
helps if you don't
have the money for therapy or whatever i
mean grieving is something
you gotta do on your own a therapist
could always help you know me i love
better help
but
this is something that you could do at
home and it's nice you you write a
journal you write a letter to them once
a month you write your goals there's a
lot of work to be done in a notebook if
you have a notebook at home it's not for
[__] you know you're not in school no
more you're not adding nothing get
yourself a notebook yeah you're not
adding nothing you know what i'm saying
get yourself a [__] notebook and you
know writing it write your thoughts down
that's called journaling that's it just
writing it what you're feeling for the
day your girlfriend's a [__] [__]
your grandmother sucks dick whatever you
could write it in there and learn how to
deal with it a lot more and if you lost
somebody
write them a letter at the beginning of
the month you'll feel a lot [__]
better i want to thank all you guys i
want to thank jessica may and i want to
thank you guys for always having my back
and always supporting the podcast and
the patreon i want to thank mike for
always [__]
doing the innovations whether it's the
lights or whatever we're always coming
up on you [__] always get a
little bit better every week so thank
you for your patience
and that's it have a great [__] week
and i'll see you [__] monday
morning
the seventh tip top magoo don't forget
we got some great fights this week mars
vidal you got [__] the whole thing
there
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you i want to thank jessamy
paluso
but most importantly i want to thank the
sponsors and everybody involved with
this show mike all you [__] but
before we get out of here the joint is
brought to you by draftkings like i said
in the beginning
mars vidal and covington they're going
into the octagon to beat the [__] out of
each other this weekend with puyol
hatred
but
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner ufc has a tremendous
[__] deal for you you ready
bet a dollar in maine on the main event
and get a hundred and free bets no
matter what getting you ready for
[__] march madness which is gonna be
tremendous this year on draftkings this
could be a first round knockout majority
draw or double knockout no matter the
outcome you get paid and if sportsbook
isn't available in your state yet don't
worry about nothing draftkings has free
pools everyone can enter a pool
for ten thousand dollars in prizes and
guess what they're [__] free free
free free what are you [__] killing
yourself for you answer a couple
questions how long the fight will last
who's gonna win who's gonna knock them
out with an elbow
follow along to track your results it's
that easy
download the draftking sportsbook ad but
if you haven't i don't know what the
[__] you're waiting for they're the best
from casino sports gambling soccer they
got it all what the [__] are we waiting
for so this weekend use promo code joey
throw down one dollar on ufc 272 main
event and get a hundred dollars in free
bets no matter what
that's code joey j-o-e-y
this saturday at draftking sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the [__] ufc
21 over restrictions do apply
it all depends on your state if you got
a problem with gambling call 1-800
gambler if not
this is the weekend to put a tremendous
[__] better than win some money the
joint is also brought to you by manscape
listen if you're like me your balls
smell like [__] that's just [__] but
at least i'm honest i'm not like you
guys walking around i got fresh balls
and nobody wants to suck them uncle joey
and manscape gonna send you to the
shower you filthy [__]
all right manscape is turning men's
showers into [__] dreams people hate
to take showers i don't know what the
[__] is wrong with you me i love to wash
my balls my [__] and you could do the
whole thing
with [__] manscape with that
collection you understand me first off
you shave a little bit of your dick trim
your [__] hairs then your leather on
the cologne infused
body wash with aloe vera and sea salt
you feel [__] clean and moisturize
all day next step i put a little
two-in-one shampoo to wash and condition
my [__] the three hairs i got left
and you can use it anywhere on your
balls your [__] your legs now to keep
the bio at bay i use a little aluminum
free deodorant it dries nice and clear
nobody knows nothing now i ain't got no
tattoos but i got dry skin you could hit
your dry skin and those [__] tattoos
with the hydrating
body moisturizer spray which is [__]
tremendous and before you step out the
door you apply the manscape lip balm
that's the free gift to you now do me a
favor okay we've been talking about
manscape for [__] years you're still
walking around with nut sacks that look
like the [__] wolf man i'm gonna give
you 20 off plus free shipping with code
diaz at manscape.com that's 20 off plus
free shipping at
manscape.com use code d i a z it's time
to [__] shower you filthy animals and
manscape is here to [__] help you the
joint is also brought to you by the best
freeze pipe with freeze pipe you get a
cold hit every [__] time here's
how it works all right the pipe comes
with a detachable chamber that you keep
in the freezers like keeping the head in
the [__] freezer when you're ready to
smoke a number
the hot smoke passes through the frozen
part right
cooling down the smoke as you inhale
your smoke will be so cold you think
you're a [__] penguin listen to me
i love the freeze pipe why because it's
the best [__] smoking you'll ever do
it goes deep deep deep into your lung
sacs and you don't even [__] feel it
or taste it even if you have susquehanna
weed it'll make it taste like [__]
you're in [__] northern california
jumping up with cheech and challenge so
do me a favor go to freezepipe.com and
press and code joey and save 10
off your first order get a bong a pipe
or a bubble i like the [__] pipe the
bong will blow your one lung out they'll
be calling you nikki one lung that's the
freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10 percent if
you can smoke from it freeze pipe will
make it
i want to thank freeze pipe i want to
thank manscape i want to thank
draftkings i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank [__] on it
and i want to thank
the best
stamps.com i want to thank peluso and i
want to thank you [__]
for always having my back i love you
[__] stay black have a great
weekend it's going to be tip top magoo
and i'll see you monday it's that easy
[Music]
so
you